اذا ميدانيا مشاهدينا ووسطى نفي اوكراني
اعلن وزاره الدفاع الروسيه تقدم القوات
الروسيه في منطقه زابوريجيا والسيطره طبعا
هناك على مواقع مهمه وسط تقدم في كافه
المحاور اذا كما نشاهد هنا ونتابع تقدم
فيزا بوريجي على كافه المحاور على المحور
الشرقي الغربي وطبعا كافه المناطق بهذه
المنطقه طبعا الجيش الروسي سيطر على خطوط
ومواقع مهمه جديده قبر قرب مناطق كما كنا
قد اعلن عنها وهي سينوجس
ومالينوفسكا بمنطقه زاباليجيه ودممر اسلحه
ومدافع للجيش الاوكراني هناك عبر هذه
المنطقه التي تعتبر طبعا اساسيه وصلتيه
بالمعركه الدائره بهذه المنطقه طبعا
القوات الاوكرانيه نفت هذا التقدم الروسي
بهذا المحور
الى دنياز حيث ايضا احرزت القوات الروسيه
تقدم على كافه عدد من المناطق هنا وتحديدا
بالمحور الجنوبي الغربي وفي مناطق محدده
هي كل من راسودولفكا وسيفرونوي واستهدفت
مخازن اسلحه للجيش الاوكراني بمنطقه
بمحور طبعا خيرسون حيث طوقت هذه المناطق
والذي يعتبر تقدم استراتيجي
وتطويق للقوات الاوكرانيه كما كنا قد
اعلنها عنا سابقا وتابعناها بالاسابيع
الماضيه من هذه المنطقه من دونيسك تحديدا
الى خير طبعا مشاهدينا قبل ان انتقل الى
الحصان المناطق المحيطه بدون يسكنك صراع
ايضا حول هذه الاثناء يدور بخارسون ايضا
هناك تقدم روسي لهذه المنطقه
وحاول قام الجيش الروسي ضمير همم معدات
واسلحه اعطيت لي اكياس من قبل طبعا الدول
الغربيه من همم الاتحاد الاوروبي ومن
الامريكيين وتحديدا تم تدمير منظومه رادار
دفاع جوي امريكيه الصنع بهذه المنطقه قبل
ان اختم هناك اليوم ايضا محاوله اوكرانيه
للسيطره على الطريق السريع وهو الذي يربط
بين الثلاث المناطق الاساسيه والذي ايضا
يعني القوات الروسيه تحاول ان ترد هذه
المحاوله الاوكرانيه بما ان السيطره عليها
تعتبر استراتيجيه
يا استاذ